hallo
herzlich willkommen in meiner trocken
ich möchte noch die fetzen saison
ausnutzen und möchte heute noch mal ein
rezept zwetschgen machen meinen
plätzchen kuchen mit dem streuseln kennt
ihr bereits der kam auch sehr gut bei
euch an und heute möchte ich auch wieder
etwas mit hefeteig machen ich bin auch
ein totaler hefeteig verein sind fans
und auch ein sketch kämpfen
und deswegen werde ich heute buchteln
machen wer nicht weiß was bucht uns sind
also bachtel nennt man auch horn modeln
und zwar sind es so gefüllte oder
ungefüllte kleine gläschen die man dann
im ofen backt und ich werde jetzt heute
mit zwetschgen füllen aber ihr könnt sie
zum beispiel auch mit marmelade füllen
sie ungerührt lassen und später zum
beispiel diese kleinen brötchen dann
aufschneiden und mit marmelade
bestreichen und essen oder ihr könnt
auch ungefüllt lassen und zu herzhaftem
essen wie sauerkraut usw
aber wie gesagt wenn ich heute die
gefüllte variante machen wird auch
wieder zu benutzen und buchten sind auch
so eine spezialität aus dem süddeutschen
aus österreich aus ungarn also mehr so
diese böhmischen länder und ich werde
sie ganze aus einem hefeteig machen und
werde ich aber zuerst einmal die zutaten
zeigen weil dann die fetzen einlegen und
dann geht's einfach gleich weiter
dieses mal war ich einen etwas anderen
hefeteig ihr braucht 500 gramm mehl 125
bis 5 200 milliliter milch 50 gramm
butter die habe ich schon verlassen
50 gramm zucker 2 eier ein würfel hefe
einen halben teelöffel salz
füllen werde ich die buchteln mit
pflaumen deswegen habe ich hier zwölf
ganze pflaumen habe hier drei esslöffel
zucker einen halben teelöffel zimt und
drei welten die können auch weggelassen
oder ausgetauscht werden durch andere
gewürze
wir brauchen 100 milliliter sahne oder
milch und noch etwas zimt zucker zum
bestreuen
zuerst werde ich jetzt die zwetschken
halbieren und entkernen
danach gebe ich sie in einen topf und
gebe den zucker und die gewürze mit dazu
und lass das ganze so etwa eine stunde
ziehen
in der zwischenzeit werde ich dann
nämlich schon mal den hefeteig
vorbereiten mein mail gebe ich in meiner
rührschüssel löse die hefe in einem
kleinen gefäß auf und gebe da etwas von
der milch dazu so etwa vier bis fünf
esslöffel die hefe löse ich dann in der
milch schön auf
und gäbe dann eine kleine mulde in das
mehl und fülle da die hefe milch
mischung ein
hier gebe ich noch etwas zucker mit dazu
damit die hebel besser aufgehen kann und
ihr seht auch schon ich arbeite hier
heute mit einem vortrag das müsst ihr
natürlich nicht aber ich finde jetzt bei
diesem rezept besonders gut
jetzt denke ich diese mischung mit etwas
mehl vom rand ab und lass das ganze
etwas ruhen so etwa 15 bis 20 minuten
bis sich die hefe deutlich vergrößert
hat
das sieht man jetzt hier auch genau
jetzt kommen einfach noch alle zutaten
mit rein also salz zucker die flüssige
butter die zweier und dann wird der teig
verknetet ich mach das jetzt in der
kitchenaid geht aber auch ganz gut per
hand jetzt gebe ich immer mal wieder
milch dazu bisschen schöner weicher
hefeteig entsteht der dann aber nicht
mehr kleben sollte den teig werde ich
dann noch mal mit der hand richtig schön
durchkneten sprühe dann meine form mit
etwas back trend spray aus und gebe da
detail kugel hinein
den teig der sich dann abgedeckt für
etwa eine stunde gehen bis er sich
mindestens verdoppelt hat in der
zwischenzeit ist etwas wasser aus den
pflaumen herausgetreten
die rühre ich jetzt kurz durch und weil
sie jetzt etwa 2 bis 3 minuten auf dem
herz etwas dünnsten so dass sie eben
etwas weicher werden und so kann ich es
auch ein bisschen mit dem zucker
karamellisieren lassen
danach schalte ich einfach den herd aus
und lasst sie einfach an der seite
abkühlen zum backen nehme ich jetzt hier
mein back trend spray und fette damit
meine form
ich habe jetzt hier eine ganz normale
auflaufform genommen
hier seht ihr auch den teig wie toll es
sich jetzt verdoppelt hat und diesen tag
nehme ich jetzt mit einer thai karte auf
meine bemehlten arbeitsfläche raus und
werde ihn jetzt in zwölf gleich große
teile verteilen dafür halbiere ich jetzt
einmal den teig und werde dann jede
hälfte in sechs gleich große teile
schneiden
indem ich sie nochmal halbiere und dann
jeweils drittel
das könnt ihr einfach nach augenmaß
machen um ist es nicht abmessen
aber da ging dann doch wieder der
perfektionist in mir durch
und ich hab dann doch wieder eine vage
genommen und nach kontrolliert und
komischerweise hatten wirklich alle 76
oder 77 gramm also wie in der
fernsehwerbung anschließend werden die
teile gleich weiter verarbeitet und zwar
öffne ich sie nur ein ganz klein wenig
gebe dann die zwetschgen hinein jeweils
zwei hälften und verschließe dann diese
teilchen oben mit zwei fingern wie so
kleine mäuse finger einfach immer wieder
zusammen zupfen so dass die pflaumen
eben nicht herauskommen beim aufgehen
und beim backen und dann drehe ich das
ganze und machen eine schöne runde kugel
draus
diese kugeln gebe ich dann alle in einer
auflaufform und zwar schichte ich sie da
dreimal vier und ihr seht auch das ganze
ist nicht schwer die samira kann das
auch schon und das könnt ihr auch gerne
wieder mit euren kindern zusammen machen
ist einfach nur darauf achten dass die
enden gut verschlossen sind so dass eben
kein flammen saft hinaus tritt und alles
wichtige und leckere im innern der
bruchstelle bleibt
jetzt ist es ganz wichtig dass ihr die
buchteln noch einmal aufgehen lassen
dass es sogar wichtiger als vorher den
teig aufgehen zu lassen
also jetzt bitte die buchteln noch mal
mindestens eine stunde lang gehen lassen
damit sie auch richtig schön und locker
werden denn nur so schmecken die
buchteln total lecker wenn sie dann auf
gehen durften sehen sie so aus ich sehe
also sie haben richtig an volumen
zugenommen sind fast so aus wie
dampfnudeln aber das sind hier rohr
nudeln also offen nudeln und jetzt
werden sie im ofen bei 175 grad für 30
minuten gebacken und nach etwa 15
minuten werde ich sie herausnehmen und
mit dieser sahne begießen dazu nehme ich
einfach einen pinsel und gibt sie dann
für die restlichen 15 minuten nochmal in
den ofen
natürlich werde ich sie auch mit dem
zucker bestreuen nachdem ich sie mit der
sahne begossen habe und damit sie
einfach eine schöne zuckerguss zu
bekommen
so sehen die buchteln jetzt nach 15
minuten aus ihr seht ist sie sind schön
hell und da kommt jetzt eben diese sahne
drauf darüber kommt der zimt zucker und
dann gehen sie noch mal zurück in den
ofen
für weitere 15 minuten
nach etwa zehn minuten habe ich gesehen
dass die sahne noch nicht aufgezogen war
deswegen habe ich sie herausgenommen und
habe die sache nochmal schön verstrichen
und die restlichen fünf minuten noch mal
durchchecken lassen so sehen dann die
fertigen leckeren buchteln aus am besten
ist man die buchteln noch warm das heißt
die schmecken ganz lecker zum frühstück
aber auch lecker mal als süßes
mittagessen oder abendessen und ihr
nehmen sie am besten mit zwei gabeln
heraus und serviert sie dann entweder so
pur oder mit einer leckeren
selbstgemachten vanillesoße die buchten
werden jetzt am besten mit zwei gabeln
zerrissen
ich würde sie nicht mit einem messer
schneiden damit sie nicht zerquetschen
weil sie noch warm sind
und die sind so lecker vor allem mit
dieser selbstgemachten vanillesoße daher
reicht nicht wenn man nur eine ist
sondern da ist man auch mal gerne zwei
oder drei oder sogar vier
und weil uns die buchteln für einen tag
zu viel man habe ich sie am nächsten tag
zum frühstück einfach noch mal in eine
kleine auflaufform geben sie nochmal mit
sahne bestrichen natürlich hätte ich
auch hier einfach milch nehmen können
und nochmal etwas zimt zucker darüber
gegeben und für fünf minuten bei 175
grad einfach nochmal aufgeheizt und so
haben wir sie dann am nächsten tag
fertig gemacht
ich hoffe euch hat dieses konzept
gefallen und schmecken die buchteln sehr
lecker und natürlich schmecken sie
frisch gut aber genauso gut dann am
nächsten tag aufgewärmt noch gut und wir
haben sie mit dieser vanillesoße
gegessen
falls ihr euch für die vanillesoße
interessiert werde ich dazu gern mal ein
kurzes video machen
ich habs jetzt ganz klassisch gemacht
mit
milch aber man kann sie auch vegan
machen und dann würde ich euch einfach
beide varianten zeigen
ich hoffe natürlich dass er mir einen
kommentar ballast ob das gericht schon
kannte oder ob das jetzt ganz neu für
euch war und ihr dürft euch jetzt gerne
ganz viele rezepte wünschen jetzt habe
ich nämlich etwas mehr zeit für youtube
und für meine videos und das nächste
video wird bestimmt schon ganz bald
folgen
ich freue mich aufs nächste mal bis bald
und bevor ich es vergesse mich wie
natürlich auch ganz persönlich noch mal
bei euch allen bedanken für die lieben
geburtstagsgrüße und das video hat mich
wirklich total überrascht ich habe mich
total darüber gefreut habe an der einen
stelle geweint weil ich so gerührt war
an der anderen stelle habe ich geweint
vor lauter lachen vor allem als samira
etwas öfter aus der asse kam
und ja ich möchte mich bei allen ganz
herzlich bedanken die mir über instagram
über e-mail über facebook oder youtube
gratuliert haben
ich bin 26 geworden im übrigen weil da
viele danach gefragt haben also ich habe
noch ein paar jahre bis zu 30 und ja mir
geht es gut und ich hab mich wirklich
total drüber gefreut vielen vielen dank
ich muss aber noch ein ofen
ja ich liebe